foreign
[Music]
you will learn how to diagnose issues
with anthos cluster running on VMware
you can use gke CTL command line utility
to diagnose issues with your anthos
cluster on VMware first let's understand
what gke CTL is and how it can be used
to diagnose cluster issues well this is
a command line utility that interacts
with your cluster running on VMware to
perform administrative tasks and health
checks on VMware GK CTL perform health
checks related to vsphere infrastructure
node pools load balancers control plane
components user workloads and many more
components on both anthos admin and user
clusters
all right now let's learn how to use gke
CTL on VMware to diagnose the issues
with our admin cluster first login to
the admin workstation of your cluster
running on VMware then execute the
displayed command
this command performs connectivity test
between control plane components and
cluster cluster health checks and
infrastructure health checks it provides
the results for each of these tests and
finally displays the overall health of
the cluster in our example we are
getting success messages for each of the
health checks and the last line states
that the cluster is healthy woohoo this
indicates that our Vital health checks
have been passed and there are no issues
with their cluster
let's look at another output that shows
some failures the message here states
that container load balancer is
unhealthy scroll down to view if there
are any further clues for the failure
the error States fail to pull the image
this typically happens if the correct
image name is not specified in the
deployment yaml file this is a familiar
error where the image is unable to be
pulled correctly
to fix the issue view the load balancers
deployment configuration
verify the image name in the yaml oops
the image is indeed wrong which is the
reason for the failure we will update
the correct image name and version once
the file is saved it will redeploy with
the updated configuration let's re-run
the diagnose command now
congratulations we have fixed the issue
with the global load balancer and our
cluster is healthy again you can use the
same command to troubleshoot the user
cluster by passing the user cluster name
as shown here you will get a similar
output containing the help check status
for individual components and overall
health of the cluster
if the diagnose results from GK CDL
command are not sufficient to determine
the root cause and or fix the cluster
issues then you can create the snapshot
of the cluster are you wondering what a
snapshot is a snapshot is a tar file
that contains the configuration files
and logs for the cluster
please note that snapshot is an
important artifact that helps Google
Cloud perform a deep type analysis and
help resolve the issues with your
cluster
remember to share the snapshot to Google
Cloud support as part of your support
case use this command to create the
snapshot for a VMware cluster keep in
mind the command not only saves the
snapshot to your local disk it also
uploads a snapshot to the storage bucket
where we have provided access to the
Google Cloud support team before running
the diagnose snapshot command complete
these prerequisites to create and share
the snapshot enable storage API in the
fleet host project using this command
Grant the storage admin role to the
service account on its parent project
Grant read-only access of the storage
bucket to the dedicated service account
provided by the Google Cloud support
team
all right we are all set let's run the
command now
we'll now use the same command along
with the name of user cluster to create
the snapshot for a user cluster once the
snapshot is shared with Google Cloud
support team they will examine the
content of the snapshot along with the
available logs and metrics in the Google
Cloud project using this information
Google will work to provide a timely
solution congratulations you now know
how to diagnose issues with your anthos
cluster on VMware Additionally you know
how to share a snapshot in situations
where the diagnostic do not help for
more information on troubleshooting
anthos cluster running on VMware check
out this documentation thanks for
watching foreign
[Music]